let them out of your relaxed dungeon
[Music]
according to our friends at the FBI
crime lab between seven and fourteen
people watching this right now are
keeping a prisoner and a sex dungeon
whether it's an abandoned warehouse
where some dudes naked body has changed
to a radiator or just a student nurse
duct-taped to the floor of your van but
it's the new year and it's the perfect
time to call Olly Olly oxen free and let
them out of your sex dungeon sure you've
got a soft spot for that young lady and
it's fun to read to her from the book of
Revelation while you stroke your tiny
genitals and weep and we know what
you're thinking hey if I let her go
they're gonna catch me lock me up and
throw away the key well in many states
that would be true but Washoe County are
clear crimes percentage is about three
percent so there's a very good chance we
will never find you or even begin to
know where to look and junior why don't
you tell the nice folks with sex
dungeons out there what our Sheriff's
Department DNA crime lab is like the
Reno Sheriff's Department does not have
a DNA crime lab we do have a mimeograph
machine but we're not allowed to touch
it because somebody broke it with their
genitalia when it comes to letting
someone out of your sex dungeon the fun
is contagious
[Music]
here at the Reno Sheriff's Department
know that the worst part of the holiday
is spending time with your family lucky
for me this year I'm alone
my uncle buzzy went missing I'm pretty
sure he just holed himself up in this
bunker in Truckee oh well more sweet
potato casserole for me in the cats if
you weren't able to get out of being
around your relatives this holiday
season we have some tips on how to get
through it peacefully so things don't
escalate and you don't end up having to
call on us that's right Jim
once we've scarf down our Christmas
pudding and slipped into our house pants
the last thing we want to do is come
break up a fight between you and your
toothless cousin Ricky over who's gonna
drive grandma to her dialysis
appointment
and now deputies will show you how a
typical holiday scenario could easily
get out of hand and how to resolve it
peaceably could you please pass the
butter grandma so this holiday always
have fresh batteries in your taser or
okay just call the fire department
hi I'm the ghost of Christmas duis past
duis you got in previous holiday seasons
drunk driving or buzzed driving and
those do you Ives have come back to
haunt you ruining your resume your
chances at child custody and your credit
rating in the ghosts of duis future if
you get one more DUI next year drunk
driving for even worse loves to drive
hit and you will lose your driver's
license your car your livelihood
[Music]
I am the post of DUIs
did you know there are a million DUI
checkpoints out there to catch you with
your drunk driving or a million times
worse how does somebody change their
ways of not drunk drive again we have no
11 users cruising 3 ghosts not it not it
I don't look good in the Hat screwed on
the yeah you think that's funny
you